definition finding al-qaeda's actions to
fit his description along with the
Allied bombing of Tokyo and Dresden in
World War two in his new book the
lessons of terror mr. Carr also argues
it's wrong in either case and that it
doesn't work from Roman massacres of
Germanic tribes under Augustus to
William Tecumseh Sherman's willingness
to let northern troops plunder southern
houses and current-day Palestinian
terrorist organizations inspired by
Israeli paramilitary groups he finds
that rather than intimidating an enemy
into submission
terrorism builds resentment that can
last for generations
it's an hour
good afternoon i'm joanne myers director
of meril house programs and on behalf of
the carnegie council I'd like to welcome
our members guests and c-span book TV to
our author in the afternoon program
today our guest is author and novelist
and military historian Caleb car and he
will be discussing his recently
published book the lessons of Terror a
history of warfare against civilians why
it has failed and why it will fail again
to introduce Mr Carr I've asked James
Chase who is the director of
globalization and international affairs
program at Bard College and also teaches
government and public law there as well
mr. Chase is a long-standing and a very
good friend of the Carnegie Council and
it just so happens he is also a very
good friend and a mentor of Caleb's in
fact in the acknowledgments two lesson
of Terror Calif makes reference to the
fact that many of ideas in this book
were first written in the form of an
article published in the world policy
journal which was at that time under the
stewardship of James before I turn the
microphone over to James I would just
also like to mention that James himself
is the author of the prize-winning
biography Atchinson the Secretary of
State who created the American world he
and Caleb also co-authored American and
vulnerable the quest for absolute
security from 1812 to Star Wars
gentlemen I thank you for joining us
today James thank you very much thank
you very much Joanna
oh she's stolen some of my Ellen I loved
it here in mentioning some killer's
works but I will say a few words in any
case yes we are very very old friend
indeed we did collaborate on a book
called American vulnerable quest for
absolute security from 1812 to Star Wars
we more or less covered the last years
of a Central American wars in Nicaragua
flee feeling that free Nevada zone to a
golf course in Costa Rica we've been
through a lot of terrifying adventures
together Caleb
most of you probably know cable car has
a novelist his buzz his book the
alienist was a major best-selling novel
in United States in recent years and
since was followed up by a sequel
equally good if not better called the
Angel of Darkness and then followed by
that by a book called The Killing Fields
a third third novel what people aren't
aware of is that caleb is also a
military historian he has been for a
number of years a contributing editor to
the military history quarterly which is
really a first-rate Journal of military
history and in addition to the articles
he's written for the military history
quarterly he hasn't even articles for
the world policy journal not only the
article which was the genesis of his
book on terrorism but also a number of
other articles on military and the
political and affairs and foreign
affairs
broadly speaking so he's he has a he's
had a long-standing reputation
I'm always among a certain among
military historians and people who are
interested in military affairs of a
particularly insightful writer on those
in that area this book the the lessons
of Terror a history of warfare against
civilians why it has always failed
and why it will fail again it's already
becoming extremely controversial book as
well it should be Caleb's Caleb's point
of view that terrorism is a problem for
the military in sponsoring states should
be held responsible the terrorism their
borders that that's their a that
terrorism any any any acts of willful
willful killing of civilians is
sense a terror a terrorist act he'll
explain that I'm sure right now in his
presentation but it isn't it's an
extreme position and it's one which many
of us agree with others have a disagree
with it is therefore my view one of the
necessary books to be read at this time
in American history when we are always
concerned with terrorism where only
yesterday the secretary head of the CIA
said quite convincingly in my view that
that would do more terrorist attacks
against against civilians in the United
States so it is the book of the moment
and it's a very challenging thesis that
he has to offers and I think we're lucky
to have him here today is also by the
way a beautifully written book thank you
James I thought I'd just take a few
minutes to explain what the genesis of
terrorism as I or my definition of
terrorism
really is in the book since that seems
to be the focal point of the controversy
that surrounds the book and is the
reason that I include the number of
people in factions under the label and
heading of terrorists that I do when I
started to study this problem really
seriously in the well warfare against
civilians is a problem I've been
studying since my youth but when I
started to turn toward what we call
modern international terrorism in the
early 90s I was looking for some way to
define it it occurred to me very early
on that terrorism although we all talked
about it very easily it's a little like
obscenity for the supreme court I don't
know what it is I know it when I see it
it nobody really has a precise very few
people have a precise definition of what
terrorism actually is but they know it
when they see it or experience it so I
went about the business of trying to
come up with a precise definition that
definition it seemed to me and the
definition that I use in the book is the
deliberate waging of war against
civilians with the purpose of affecting
those civilians loyalty to their
political leaders or the
policies of those political leaders that
definition as I began to look at it
through a historical lens seemed to me
to go back much farther than the period
we usually think of as being the
terrorists period generally people think
of the modern terrorists period as
beginning with the 1960s the 1970s
perhaps going back as far as the 1950s
if we if we include go slightly farther
afield but certainly no more than that
as I went into the subject more and more
I discovered that it went back farther
and farther the the the place I chose to
begin the book historically was with
ancient Rome I could have gone back
farther than that but ancient Rome was
it seemed to me the ancient Romans were
the first ones to really intellectualize
and codify and systematize the idea of
deliberately making war on civilians in
order to cut their support for their
political and military leaders the
example I use specifically in the book
to illustrate this with Rome is the
example of the German rebellion in the
first century there are any number
obviously of of other examples that
could be used from the period of ancient
Rome and from there I I follow it pretty
much straight through to modern times
but it's this idea which some people
have said is broad some people have said
inexcusably broad some people have said
justly broad it's the broadness of this
definition that I think has been
responsible for the controversy because
what if what it means simply is that a
great many people more people are
brought under the terrorists tent than
have been up until this point
even people who are sympathetic toward
modern terrorism like to think of it
specifically as where many of them like
to think of it specifically as somehow a
form of warfare developed by oppressed
nations by nations who don't have
expansive conventional military
establishments at their disposal that
this is somehow the what we always hear
referred to as the asymmetrical
warfare that this is somehow the warfare
of a certain class of a certain type
what I found going back was that
terrorism is in fact not confined simply
to classes simply to economic strata
that in fact states are just as capable
of committing terrorism as our extremist
groups and that really it wasn't just to
declare terrorism simply to be the
warfare of the extreme if we define it
as I do and I encourage anyone who's
present here who has a counter
definition when the article in nineteen
ninety six that came out that James
published in the world policy journal
when that came out we got a great deal
of flack from a lot of terrorism experts
in a lot of other people who said that
that definition was too broad but they
were unable to provide us with
alternative definitions and the only
person who indeed did provide us with an
alternative definition was someone who I
admire very much Bruce Hoffman who at
the time was at the st. Andrews
terrorism interest Institute is now at
the RAND Corporation the problem was
that Bruce and as I say I am a great
admirer of his work but his definition
simply rearranged the work to my ears
simply rearranged the words a little by
saying that terrorism was political
violence that was aimed at
non-combatants with the aim of effecting
political change and as I wrote to him
and I said I don't I can't I can see
where you've changed the the wording
around booth but I can't really see what
you've changed the meaning and what I
haven't really been able to find anyone
to come up with a coherent definition
one that is not in some way built to
serve the interests of some specific
group narrowing the definition usually
serves the interests of one side of the
spectrum or the other so I'd like to
sort of wrap up these initial comments
by just inviting anyone in the question
and answer session if you have a better
definition of terrorism I'd be happy to
hear it and I'd be happy to hear any
other questions
that you might have on the subject keep
your question fairly brief to the point
and we've been asked that you wait until
the microphone is thank you with you
Richard you see it if we know what it is
when we see it why do we need a
definition if we know what it is when we
see it why do we need a definition
well like obscenity I don't think you
can have a coherent policy towards
something that you don't define we don't
have a coherent policy towards obscenity
which is part of the reason why
pornography has become one of the most
profitable industries in this country if
we had a good definition of obscenity
that probably wouldn't have happened I
don't think we can formulate an adequate
answer to terrorism if we can't define
it how has policy towards terrorism
changed with changing definitions well I
think once you in once you change the
definition you can change the who it is
that you include within that that form
of action and if we take the example of
the United States in particular which is
an area in which I've gotten a certain
amount of negative feedback because of
my willingness to include certain
Americans under the category of
terrorists that seems to be to me to be
a very useful place in which we can
although we need now to solve the
problem of terrorism in the way in which
I think we're responding to it quite
correctly in the war in Afghanistan I
think it's the first time that we've
managed to formulate a response that has
made a very concerted effort and I think
secretary Rumsfeld is to be commended
for his attempts to make sure that we
got men on the ground early try to
contact the civilian population try to
at least try to figure out who was with
us who was against us try to figure out
what were civilian areas what what
places were really masquerading as
civilian areas I think that that is part
of the policy definitely to answer the
terrorist threat now but also part of
the policy is to accept that many of the
regions that are engaged in terrorist
may have legitimate grievances against
actions that the Americans have taken in
the past which should well be classified
as terrorist actions and part of the
only way an effective dialogue will open
up is if Americans will own up to that
kind of behavior in the past that's why
in the book I well there's also been a
great deal of talk about the fact that
in the book I labeled the CIA in II in
effect in many ways an Oregon of state
terror many of its actions have been in
effect terrorist actions I say that one
of the clearest ways that we could
indicate to the rest of the world that
were serious about changing policy in
those parts of the world is to disband
the CIA and a lot of people think that
that's an extreme idea I don't happen to
think it's an extreme idea our former
senator Patrick Daniel Patrick Moynihan
doesn't think it's an extreme idea there
are a lot of very capable people who
don't think it's an extreme idea mainly
because the CIA is a redundant
organization but most of all it's not a
Central Intelligence Agency
it doesn't mainly engage in the
intelligence gathering and research its
main effect politically abroad is to
undercut the moral authority of the
United States by engaging in activities
that are borderline or wholly terrorist
in nature
I'm wondering if you would consider
Hiroshima an example of terrorism this
has been a this has also been the
subject of great of great conversation
because in the book I do say that in
effect the dropping of the atomic bomb
was a terrorist action the caveat there
is that the the the action itself was
represented to President Truman as being
one that was aimed at military targets
now whether or not that representation
was disingenuous I'll never know I'm not
sure anyone will ever know whether
Truman in his heart really believed that
those targets were military or not I
will never know they were certainly
represented as being important military
targets they ended up it's in reality it
turned out the military targets on those
sites were insignificant and certainly
he had every reason to know they were
contained within large civilian areas so
yes
I would have to say that in effect the
dropping of the atomic bomb was a
terrorist action in that it ended up
killing civilians but it's really the
important question here is motivation
when are we deliberately destroying
civilian life was Truman - in his mind
deliberately killing civilians that I'm
not entirely clear about and I don't
know that anybody ever can be - Olson
I would be edified by specific examples
of act I'm sorry acts of CIA terrorism
preferably well documented acts of CIA
terrorists yes sir
okay how far back do you want to go 47 I
believe is the origin of the origin of
the CIA yes we had every reason to the
CIA had every reason to expect believe
and know that it's operative actions in
I'll begin with the early stuff with the
actions against Mossadegh in Iran the
actions in Guatemala they had every
reason to suspect no and believed that
those would result in civilian deaths as
indeed they did result in civilian death
we were not in a state of declared or
even undeclared hostility with any with
either of those nations the the the
certainly the scope of operations in
which the CIA was involved grows from
then on and eventually culminates in CIA
operations throughout Southeast Asia
which well doesn't culminate it grows to
a much larger point then if you consider
the operations described by Edward
Lansdale in his recollections of what
they were signed to do in Southeast Asia
throughout the 60s and 70s certainly
they had specific civilian targets as
well as general civilian targets which
they had every every CIA officer who was
involved in them was that heat that he
spoke of was willing to confess that in
fact they were civilian targets they
simply believed that we were at a war
with a at the nation to gain the hearts
and minds of the nation part of that was
to reward civilians and part of it was
to punish civilians they were great
believers in that we go on from there
two instances of CIA trained training
other people to conduct terrorist
actions I don't think that anybody would
really be in any doubt that the CIA has
certainly trained organizations that we
would call terrorists perhaps the
greatest example being the people that
were fighting now there would have been
no problem of the Mujahideen in
Afghanistan there would have been
probably no problem about Qaeda had it
not been of the Taliban if had it not
been for the arming of those groups by
the CIA they had every reason to know
they witnessed it themselves that those
weapons would be used against Afghan
civilians that's purposeful targeting of
civilians in the name of a political
goal I don't know that you can call it
anything else
I have Jerry Liu wine New York two
things one is yeah we're in this
dialogue here that you're talking about
it seems to me there's an element of
self-defense that we're talking about
when you're trying to change a policy of
war against us in the process killing
civilians so I think you can address
that the other question I had really was
the topic that is listed here why is it
failed and why will it fail again
understanding the first part of your
question right I think that their
interconnect does too - very not
connected when a nation chooses to
answer a terrorist attack with a
terrorist attack that perpetuates a
cycle of self-defeating action which and
the reason why I subtitled the book why
war warfare against civilians why it has
always failed why it will fail again
it see it I found going back 2,000 years
that whenever a nation or a group
attacked the civilians in another nation
with the purpose of affecting their
political stance or their political
loyalties what actually happened was
that the loyalties of those civilian
populations were if anything steeled
they were not affected they were they
were actually strengthened I found this
beginning with the Germans fighting the
Romans followed it all the way through
the resistance of the British to the
German blitz to the bombing of London or
the German answer to the Allied bombing
of Germany during which the entire
period of time the Allies were bombing
civilian centers in Germany German
industrial production rose and Lisbon in
the German army not only rose but the
age ranges expanded from very young
children to very old men it is very
tempting as we have seen recently when
your civilians are attacked to wish to
attack in kind I think that that's why
what we've seen with secretary Rumsfeld
design of this war why it has been such
a radical departure in such a really
important departure from our tradition
because a real concerted effort for the
first time in modern American military
history a concerted effort has been made
to identify civilians and to avoid
casualties
of course there have been mistakes now I
get the argument from the other side but
we've looked at all these cases that are
now coming up all these Afghan civilians
that we've mistakenly killed that's the
word mistakenly we did not go in as the
CIA often did as certain people who were
responsible for certain campaigns in
Cambodia who shall remain nameless
because they're probably across the
street as they as they themselves did
purposefully designed the deaths of
civilians civilian deaths in this war
have been accidental have been what we
call collateral damage collateral damage
by definition is accidental I hope that
answers both of parts of your question
if you're trying to kill civilians to
get a government that's making war
against us to stop the war since the
government is controlling the civilians
no you can guess I prefer I I think your
solution is better go after the people
in charge and try to attack them and
what if that's failing is well what are
your alternatives if you just can't turn
that group around I don't I think you'll
find that throughout history whoever
whenever anybody has said we're
attacking an army and it's not working
let's attack the civilians which is what
you're suggesting I don't think you can
cite me an example where that policy has
worked if you're attacking the army and
it's not working it's not going to work
and it's not gonna work any better by
attacking the civilians that's what we
found in Vietnam we attacked the army it
didn't work we attacked the civilians it
worked even more poorly in the south I
mean this was allegedly his march to
Atlanta his his scorched earth policy
which is shorten the war that ended
ended so that so that cut off the south
and in Jordan civilians were killed was
that it was that Adil it was that
collateral damage Oh was that deliberate
Sherman's Sherman's march is a very
central point in the book because it
represents a campaign that was both it
was one of the most brilliant purely
military moves that's in American
military history yet Sherman in in terms
of attacking the lines of supply and
community
nation of the armies to the north that
were engaged in grant but at the same
time Sherman allowed he said he couldn't
prevent his men from committing
depredations against the civilian
population by his own admission eighty
percent of the damage that his army did
in the South was militarily useless
twenty percent he said was the twenty
percent that caused Lee's the the
weakening of Lee's army in the north the
eighty percent that was militarily
useless however it was not politically
meaningless it caused a dramatic
heightening of bitterness in the south
and was directly responsible for the
creation of postwar creation of many of
the native terrorist groups that grew up
in the area including the Ku Klux Klan
so it's it's a very good example of how
a campaign can sometimes have both
elements and had Sherman been able to
restrict that campaign as I believe he
would have Sherman was an immensely and
I have a lot of admiration for Sherman
in a lot of ways but he was an immensely
vengeful almost biblical eventful man
and he really did believe that the
southern population deserved whatever
they got and he considered himself as he
said many times to be at war with every
man woman and child in the south that
didn't help the northern cause the war
would have been won without it as I say
in the book and the peace was lost
because of it
I'm the Egyptian ambassador to the
United Nations we have here thank you if
terrorism and counterterrorism would
bring a political conflict and to a
standstill
then how would you characterize the
current situation between the
Palestinians and the Israelis were some
Palestinian groups not all of them but
some of them are targeting Israeli
civilians while in return the Israelis
are applying the extrajudicial killings
or the terrorizing of Palestinian
populations in the book I traced that I
do trace the history of the the Middle
Eastern situation back to the 1938 back
farther than the 1930s but the 1930s is
where we really see the coalescence of
two specific sort of two sides that are
specifically organizing themselves along
terrorist lines organizing cell-based
terrorist groups to commit actions not
only gets each other in these in the
Israeli case you have actions committed
against the British who were occupying
at the time and against moderate Jews
many moderate Jews were killed simply
because they weren't considered
strenuous a strenuous enough in their
support of the Israeli ideal by the
urban and the Stern gang by Menachem
bagans people who began later becoming
Prime Minister it's a it's one of those
situations that seems to be hopeless
because we have a conflict between two
sides both of whom are perfectly willing
to adopt terrorist tactics and it's it's
it's so painfully interesting because
both have solid reason to believe that
their behavior is not only unsuccessful
but there are other ways to do things if
you look at the beginning of the
Intifada movement among the Palestinians
when they made a conscious decision to
go after is written only members of the
Israeli army only units of the Israeli
army you saw an enormous spike in public
opinion throughout the world in favor of
the Palestinian movement when they chose
to go after only only only military
units unfortunately government policies
in the West did not follow fast enough
on the on the public opinion polls in
the opinion of the Palestinian groups
that were responsible for the for the
movement and they therefore fell back on
the
policy of targeting Israeli civilians
that was an extremely unfortunate
decision it's my belief that it's about
if the Palestinians had stayed with a
policy of attacking only Israeli
military units it would have been costly
to them in terms of losing their own
their own people that they sent out but
they're losing them now God knows but it
would have kept public opinion rising on
their side instead public opinion went
back to favoring or at least to mostly
favoring especially in this in this
country I don't think we would deny that
public opinion mostly particularly right
now is um is uh there's there's a
tremendous imbalance in favor of Israel
we hear endless reporting of Palestinian
terrorist actions in the Middle East we
hear very little reporting of Israeli
terrorist actions and when they are
reported they're not represented as
terrorist actions the Israeli military
or Israeli Special Forces units can kill
as many Palestinian citizens as they
want to there was the famous Sanders
incident a couple of months ago where
the knapsack was left by the roadside
and children finding it were Palestinian
children finding it were killed that was
reported for about twelve hours as I
recall on American media disappeared
it's it's an awful situation because you
have two sides that are willing to adopt
this tactic and until one or the other
of them rejects it you're not gonna I
don't see that there's any solution
military activity or that the two realm
of terrorism how you I would use a
military hit stop you right there no let
me continue how would you as a military
historian distinguish among let's say
insurgencies counterinsurgency
revolutionary activities unconventional
warfare and so on which are really
differentiations of some of the military
things that you're talking about I think
there's a there's a long chapter in the
book that deals with the with the with
the differences and similarities between
guerrilla warfare and terrorist warfare
the great guerrilla leaders of not only
the 20th century but going straight back
to Napoleonic Wars when guerrilla
warfare really began
or took its name at least always
understood that their first
responsibility was to maintain a sound
base among the civilian population they
rise from the civilian population
Mott's a tongue formulated his famous
doctrines of guerrilla warfare bait
their first and foremost basis was
maintain the loyalty and the goodwill of
the civilian population now that's not
to say that there weren't that there
weren't times at which that those rules
were violated what it is to say however
is by attempting to stay within those
boundaries those guerrilla leaders were
immensely successful the two I'm
thinking of most importantly Mott say
Tong and Ho Chi Minh probably the two
most successful guerrilla leaders of the
20th century as we've seen lately it
would have been perfectly easy for Ho
Chi Minh to send terrorist agents into
the United States to commit terrorist
acts within the domestic United States
in order to spread more confusion more
fear among the American people that was
a month between hoe and job that was a
conscious decision not to take the war
to America in that way because they
understood where the boundaries were
they decided to remain focused on
American military units and slowly but
surely not only did they gain the
loyalty of more and more people in their
own country they gained the sympathy of
more and more people in the United
States and that was their goal military
and the South Vietnamese military but
didn't go out to the South Vietnamese
civilians and political leaders and the
police officers and so on is that what
you're saying what I am saying is
incredulous what I am saying is that
their plan was to be perceived and in
many cases in in much of their campaign
in fact was directed at military
personnel people who they believed or
knew to be in some way connected with
military or intelligence personnel of
course there were especially among the
Vietcong there were units that
absolutely engaged in CIA style
assassinations of civilians listen to
new dynamics in the matter the vehicle
in my opinion were a terrorist
organization I see a con Wendy's North
Marriott but when you say about mounts
are doing at Oh Chi Minh and so on
keeping
the piece or keeping the goodwill of the
people around them that was done also at
the point of a gun and those who did
this dis disagreed with them were those
who in any way violated their rules were
shot and so I think that that's the way
that they maintained the goodwill if you
will the forced goodwill of the people
around them I think I think we could we
could certainly have an argument all
night over whether matzo Tong kept
control over China completely at the at
the point of a gun where the Ho Chi Minh
was able to conduct the war in Chau in
North and South Vietnam for as long as
he was able to completely at the point
of the gun I don't think that you could
really make that argument militarily
lion-o Collette matza Chile program
officer Carnegie Council if I understand
you correctly then you would perceive
the firebombing of Dresden to be
essentially a terrorist action
absolutely okay even though
self-defeating terrorist action the tide
of the war had turned though you would
you would concede that I mean the site
of the war turning had nothing to do
with the firebombing of Dresden high
industrial production in the areas
around Dresden and other in other areas
Hamburg and other areas only went up
mm-hmm
which meant that the numbers of weapons
tanks and men that were reaching the
fundament frontlines to fight the allied
military were increasing as a result of
German determination and anger which was
being bred by buying of civilian area
okay and then turning to the bombing
campaign in Serbia in spring 1999
particularly let's take one reference
point the bombing of the Chinese embassy
how would you proceed that was yeah this
is this is one the the the Americans
love to say that the situation in Serbia
was resolved by a bombing campaign alone
in which proved that air strikes alone
could resolve a military situation in
doing so they choose to ignore other
factors that are equally if not more
important that you cannot underestimate
in Serbia the withdrawal of Russian
support you can't and and and even at
that those who like to say for instance
that the KLA was somehow conducted a
successful terrorist
or if you would like to tell me that
Kosovo being a nation which has kept a
lot a small nation which suffered a
genocide because of the sin in
retaliation for terrorist activities
suffered a genocide is kept alive by
foreign goodwill and its people by
peacekeepers if that is considered a
military victory then we have to we're
going to have a problem with definitions
Richard this is unbought stabbings a
lawyer and businessman a Richards
question pretty much subsumed mine but
his terrorism ever justified I'm
thinking for instance of a group trying
to expel another group such as the
Algerians in the Algerian war getting
rid of the French yeah it's it's it's
it's it's not a it's it's it's not a
question so much of I was dealing more
with the practical question of whether
it as were really succeeds if we're
getting into the moral question of
whether it's really ever justified I
don't think you can say that it's
justified in the in the case of Algeria
is another one that a lot of people like
to bring up and and view the ayah the
terrorist actions of Algerian terrorists
completely in isolation from what was
occurring in France in other parts of
the French Empire at the time or French
spheres of influence at the time what
was a Algerian attacks against actual
military forces not just against
civilians how much Algerian terrorism
actually had to do with the downfall of
French power in Algeria certainly is is
absolutely debate debatable but whether
we can consider that morally justified I
don't think that it's ever really
morally justified and what I suggest in
the book is that there are certain forms
of military behavior over the last two
thousand years
slavery genocide piracy these are all
things that we have finally said no
matter what your cause is these are
forms of behavior that are simply beyond
the pale and when you reach for them you
lose all legitimacy your cause loses its
legitimacy if we go back to reading
wattles law of nations which I talked a
lot about in the book he defined he said
that really in war we can't just define
the justness of a cause by its but by
the cause itself we must define it by
the means which the side
is to fight and that aside a given side
and every side in a conflict believes
that it's right and that aside can
actually lose whatever justness it has
by reaching for means which are immoral
and unjust and I do believe that that's
a law we should really revive and apply
to terrorism I believe there are
certainly among Palestinian terrorists
among many terrorist groups in the world
right now there are causes underlying
them that deserve real attention and
they have genuine grievances but once
you reach for the tactic of deliberately
targeting civilians I think you have to
then put people outside the pale of
civilized discussion and say we're not
going to deal with you while that's
going on and that's why I think it was
such a tragedy that the ends of father
turned to get turned away from the
policy of targeting specifically
military units because at that point the
world was no longer willing to listen
million he would like to make a comment
like nations in fact we have been trying
United Nations for many years to define
terrorism as you may imagine and one of
the problems we have been faced with is
what is terrorism what is the legitimate
struggle of liberation and the problem
is that in fact the confusion which
exists today
has been created by the colonial powers
who have depicted all those who have as
we that we see as freedom fighters as
terrorists so Mandela is a terrorist and
the original freedom fighters we're
terrorists also for the French as well
other combatants who were trying to
liberate their country from foreign
colonial occupation so in the case of
Algeria for instance I don't think it is
really it's not because they have in the
past I don't think it is really a
debatable case you know when you have
let me just say very simply that in
Algeria from 54 to 60 - we had
liberation war we lost one when one
point milli 1.5 million Algerians the
French lost like 35 or 40 thousand
people and we had at a certain moment
500,000 soldiers in Algeria the
population was about 10 million at that
time French was very mighty while very
powerful it had the bombs and the tanks
and whatever to to face the unsure in
rebellion was it right or no for the
Algerians with their small and poor
means to to use tactics that could be
characterized us as terrorists I really
don't know when when when when you are
faced with a very strong powerful enemy
who is occupying your country there is
it is it I think there's something that
Americans if I may interrupt it's
something that Americans can perhaps
relate to in the case in the case that
you're talking about is we mustn't
forget in the case of Algeria the French
willingness to turn to terrorist
policies in reaction and there are
unquestionably attacks against civilians
by Algerian nationalists there's no
question about that but there were
French willingness to target civilians
in return create created within France
itself a certain revulsion with French
tactics in exactly the way in the United
States that our willingness to answer
Vietcong attacks or actually our
willingness to attack civilians arguably
preceded much of Vietcong activity but
we won't get into splitting hairs the
point is that are a domestic revulsion
with our willingness to answer terror
with terror was a very strong factor in
weakening our effort in Vietnam and Ho
Chi Minh and and and vu Nguyen Giap knew
that they understood that the American
people would eventually become disgusted
with their own behavior in Vietnam and
they did so I don't know that you can
ever really say that politically it's
it's a successful tactic I don't know if
that if that address is your point but
it's it's I think there's a similarity
there whatever whatever the current
situation in Algeria
which is certainly difficult ask you
regarding the piece of terribly whether
it's successful not the question of
course of Ireland I would think that I
don't know your reaction the tournament
terrorism's failed in Ireland because in
a sense they didn't succeed in their
aims people are tired of it and such a
revulsion on both sides right time has
passed and therefore I think effect of
the hours things the tragedy of Ireland
is not only not only did it fail since
nineteen-sixteen has Irish terror failed
and you can see that immediately in the
case of Michael Collins who however many
attempts are made to romanticize him in
Hollywood and elsewhere Michael Collins
who eventually left the guerrilla
campaign and bled over into terrorist
activities which begin which which bred
so much resentment not only among the
British but among his own supporters
that eventually he was forced to accept
terms the original terms that the
British were offering the Irish national
Nationalist Party in 1916 so the entire
terror campaign went for naught and
Collins himself was murdered by his own
people that pattern however was
romanticized and propagated in other
countries the Irish at the Irish
terrorists have always been particularly
good at representing themselves as being
immensely successful despite the fact
that the British have never been willing
to make concessions based on terrorist
actions they have been willing to
negotiate with parties like the Irish
National Party who were the people who
got the original terms of the beginnings
of self-government in in 1921 and I know
there's never been any evidence that
Irish terrorism has secured anything
except bitterness death and more trouble
the problem I think is with the title of
this thing if you're trying to say that
warfare against civilians will always
fail that I mean manifestly that isn't
true because it's frequently very very
successful but then you've heard all
these examples but the creation of the
Irish Free State after presence of the
IRA and the government of Northern
Ireland spade a spade Spain's the most
decentralized country in Europe because
of because of the Basques and esse the
French government has just been forced
to make a very painful decision to give
a great deal of autonomy to Corsica
which costed a minister from the Cabinet
I gained because of her because of
Corsican violence mama was really the
the end of the colonial dream in Kenya
is an East Africa
then we have Algeria Mozambique and
Angola the question is can you really
say that any of those things were
because of terrorism there were so many
other forces in play in every one of
those examples the end of colonialism in
East Africa was going to happen whether
the Mau Maus that were there not the end
of British colonialism was happening
throughout the world at the time the
single greatest example of the end of
British colonialism which was a much
more successful example if you look at
the comparative state of the two
countries was India which was a
completely not completely but a
basically a non-violent form of
revolution the warfare against civilians
if you're saying that warfare against
civilians and but but does not work then
you cannot prove that it does work
frequently well I suppose we just have
to agree to disagree but if you read the
book I think you may find an argument to
the contrary
I didn't understand how you try to prove
that there was a relationship between
the fact that the productivity in
Dresden for example went up and
terrorism encouraged it to go up you
seem to imply that the result of the
bombing of of Dresden which you call
terrorism caused the productivity to go
up and I I don't think you made that
clear at all could you explain your
thinking I can explain my thinking it's
extremely well documented even in the
most basic histories of the Second World
War I'm trying to think of when I can
give him particularly probably basil a
little hearts history the Second World
War is probably got the clearest tables
on it that German industrial production
takes a remarkable spike upwards when
the American and British campaign of
strategic bombing commences and it
continues to go upward as the American
campaign intensified and when asked
after the war what was it that made the
that what was it that major 'men
industrial production go up what was it
that made you join the army thousands
and thousands of Germans interviewed
said the attacks of American and British
air forces against civilian populations
was what caused us to stiffen our
resistance it's it's it's not it's no
it's no longer even an argued fact in
military history Thank You Roz Goldberg
well I agree with your general thesis I
am troubled by the parallel that you
have drawn between the actions of the
Palestinians and the actions of the
Israeli army you may know more about it
than I do
but it is my understanding that whereas
the Palestinians and I agree with you
tragically seek out civilian targets it
is my understanding that the Israeli
army targets the facilities and
infrastructure of the Palestinian
Authority and to some extent also known
offices and centers for Hamas and other
terrorist groups doesn't mean that
civilians aren't killed in the process
but I again my understanding from
everything I've read those casualties
would be considered using your terms as
collateral damage okay do you know the
story of the infamous knapsack story of
about two months ago there was an
attempt there was an attempt sniper that
shot a ten month old baby in his
mother's arms which got zero publicity
despite your comment that that the
publicity hey I think I just got
finished explaining that we have a
conflict in the Middle East in which
both sides are willing to employ
terrorist activity so I'm not going to
argue with you that the Palestinians are
directing terrorist activities in the
Middle East that's absolutely true
however the Israelis have instituted
policies which they have every knowledge
will result in civilian death when you
leave a knapsack full of explosives set
to blow up by the next people by the
next person who picks it up and it
happens to be a group of school children
that's a terrorist activity that was
done by the Israeli Secret Service or it
may have been the American the Israeli
military we're not really sure which but
the fact of the matter is Israel's
willingness to even consider warfare
against civilians you I don't think you
really need to look farther than the
fact that Israel is willing to elect a
man like arrow shown to be Prime
Minister in the first place a man who
has a record of certainly of violating
any military rules we sit around talking
about treatment of our treatment of
military whatever we call our prisoners
in Guantanamo Bay if you go back to
Ariel Sharon's treatment of prisoners in
Lebanon for which he was very nearly
jailed and in my opinion should have
been the willingness to elect such a man
to the prime ministership of your
country is certainly a while' it shows a
certain comfort with being willing to
target civilians connection that's not
necessarily I don't know about the
knapsack affair if it is as you state I
agree with you completely in there but
the election of Sharon does not prove
your point
sure
sure-sure wants to change the topic
Jerry I don't want to change the topic
but I don't want it
excuse me I don't want it I don't want
to incite it right either but but the
Israelis at least recently and let's
forget about what Tron did or didn't do
20 years ago that I don't want to argue
about that but recently what I read and
this woman is trying to refer to is that
the targets of the Israeli attacks seem
to be leaders leaders of groups that are
causing these civilian terrorist acts
what is that it that seems to me to be
the effective scenario that you're
describing which is to go after military
targets don't try to get civilians there
may be collateral damage is it having
the effect it certainly is may be a
cause for the Israeli sympathies to go
up here but it doesn't seem to be
turning the population of the
Palestinians around any maybe it's
inciting them or maybe it's again just
the leadership groups that are causing
what appears to be the populations being
excited you're you that there's a lot of
qualifications in there the word
recently that word seemingly that you
simply if you're going to engage in a
campaign to assassinate people who are
well hidden among a civilian population
as the Palestinians have hidden their
terrorist leaders among the civilian
population if you're going to engage in
a policy of trying to go after and kill
these guys
an assassination against the belligerent
enemy is a perfectly legitimate form of
warfare we tried many times during the
Second World War to assassinate Adolf
Hitler and either we know the British
could get an even close to pulling it
off but we tried and it was a legitimate
tactic if Europe but if you're going to
if you're going to attempt a tactic like
that you need to be awfully sure that
you're not even more sure that you are
not going to incur civilian deaths
because you know that those people are
extremely well hidden among civilians
there
where the danger is all the greater let
me give you an example in the Clinton
administration there was an just the
kind of tendency to pull this kind of
assassin Ettore assassination attempts
from the air the Clinton administration
had a pathological fear of putting
soldiers on the ground to try to paint
their targets the exact thing that
secretary Rumsfeld has not proved afraid
to do cruise missiles tactical bombers
long-range bombers the Clinton
administration was convinced that we
could have clean Wars that we could win
wars without suffering any casualties
ourselves what happened the
aforementioned destruction of the
Chinese embassy
the famous destruction of the
pharmaceutical company in the Sudan
which to this day has never been proved
to have been creating biological weapons
and indeed if it had been creating
biological weapons the death toll in
Sudan in in the Sudan itself and the
surrounding area area would likely have
been huge because when you incinerate
biological weapons with aerial bombs
they tend to spread all over the place
the Willing that's Houston it was really
I thought the question was the Israeli
campaign not the Palestinian reaction
we're into China and aspirin factories
and things like that well I'm giving you
a comparison the Israelis are doing the
exact same thing that the Clinton
administration was doing they are not
taking enough care to discriminate their
targets that's why you end up having car
loads and bus loads of Palestinians to
the citizens being killed by missile
strikes on missiles launched from an
airplane is not a discriminatory weapon
you'd better have somebody on the ground
who can tell you this man is in this car
right now they're not taking enough care
to do that and as a result too many of
their actions not all of them not all of
them but too many of them end up being
terrorist in nature
and it's obvious that's a light motif is
to agree to disagree but I'd like to
invite you to continue the conversation
and Caleb's book is available and he
would be happy to sign it and I thank
you for joining us thank you all for
coming very much
Kalib car is a contributing editor at
mhq the quarterly Journal of military
history an author of the lessons of
terror
a history of warfare against civilians
why it has failed and why it will fail
again it's published by Random House for
more information or to read an excerpt
visit their website at random calm